- Cercai di prendere il pezzo di m***a e lo buttai fuori
dal finestrino
Ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata di Vita Buttata, il tema della
puntata di oggi è "La prima volta"
Per un
tema così importante ho deciso di
chiedere aiuto in realtà non solo una
persona, ma un gruppo di persone, un
sinodo di individui che come potete
vedere alle mie spalle appartengono
magari un canale che qualcuno di voi
seguirà. Non sono negli studios di casa
mia ma sono negli studios della Valle
Spaziale, quindi senza bisogno di
aggiungere altro eccovi gli Space Valley... fatevi un grande applauso
- Io pensavo apparissmo, tipo magia del montaggio
- Era quello che voleva essere, infatti non
ho capito però... - No era bello
no era molto
rocambolesco e per questo ti ringrazio
- Intanto ciao, scusa, ciao - Se non conoscete questo format è molto
semplice, quello che facciamo è ascoltare
dei messaggi legati a un tema in
particolare e li commentiamo - Ok - La cosa
migliore è partire subito con i messaggi
che poi ci si scioglie e magari persone
che magari hanno un bel bagaglio di
esperienze, potrà condividere con noi - Ok, ma perché guardi me? - Sta guardando solo te
Voi non sapete ma Cesare ha un aneddoto
per ogni cosa e questo aneddoto
solitamente ha a che vedere con la m***a. con la s***a o col p***o - Un bel equilibrio - Ottima sintesi - Accetto
Tra l'altro mi fa ridere che ci stiamo
tutti pulendo i denti con la lingua
Se volete si può continuare a mangiare - Io per ora preferisco pulire il palato - Apri la
bocca come i coccodrilli - Ma di solito gli audio che ti arrivano
sono tosti? Ci dobbiamo aspettare
qualcosa di veramente scoppiettante?
- Allora dipende tanto dal tema, la prima
volta ... - Si può spaziare - Esatto! Diciamo
che si spazia in generale proprio a
livello fisico - Ma voglio capire quanta
responsabilità abbiamo noi - Zero - Possiam dire e
fare quello che vogliamo - Non abbiamo
nessun limite?
siamo un programma family friendly
Questa cosa vuol dire, che tutto quello
che viene detto o viene bippato o tagliato - Ah perfetto
- Abbiamo avuto Tommaso Zorzi ragazzi, cioè
potete dire quello che vi pare
- "Sono libero - Sei libero - Sono libero"
Ciao Gu, per il sondaggio prima volta sarò veloce perché è alquanto imbarazzante
Primissima volta
con il mio primo fidanzato in auto, al
buio mentre il tizio cercava la
giusta vita di entrata, fallendo più volte
a un certo punto si sposta, prende il
telefono che all'epoca non aveva
l'applicazione "torcia", e accende il display per
fare luce , puntarmelo lì ed esclamare
"Dove c***o è questo buco! - Ma come? - Io ero impietrita!
Col Nokia 33 10 Ma questo era un
minatore
Più che altro è il dire "Ma non trovo il b**o", cioè a me è quello che mi pare strano
nel senso non lo dici, lo pensi - Ma gli punti la torcia poi? - Adesso c'è il gps, comunque è più tranquilla
con un telefono di nuova generazione è più facile             - Alcuni hanno il sensore che fa "bip bip" più ti
avvicini - Quello del parcheggio? -Ci sono anche
certe mattine che hanno un dispositivo
apposta credo che proprio rileva b***i, vicino alle doppie frecce - Quello è il cambio
- Beh va bene, grazie per l'amarezza, grazie per questo momento
*Cassa squilla*
- Sarà un telefono di qualcuno... - Ah è il mio! - Eh rispondi Frank - Pronto...
- Buongiorno, sono Roberto dal centro assistenza di Amazon, il corrierre
ha bisogno della
sua assistenza per trovare dove si trova
Questa chiamata può essere registrata per
motivi di addestramento, il corriere ha
chiuso la chiamata, mi dispiace, ma lui è
molto vicino al punto di consegna
- Andiamo a cercarlo - Grazie scusi - Buon lavoro. A caccia del corriere! - Grande! Bravo corriere!
- Ciao Gu ciao ospite, volevo raccontarti di
quella volta in cui eravamo in macchina
e... nella, presi dalla passione incominciamo a
fare cose ecco, l'unico problema è stato
quando durante l'atto, non so cosa mi....
cosa mi successe però c***i
Nooooooooooo!!!! - Io presa dal panico perché non volevo fare una brutta figura naturalmente
cercai di prendere il pezzo di m***a e lo buttai fuori dal finestrino perché era in macchina...
però lui se ne accorse e nulla
- Grazie. Campionessa! - Sono a postp così - Si, abbiamo fatto il video - Quei 10 secondi
in cui sei lì che dici "what a f***. what a f***! - Sono due prime volte in una
- Era il classico effetto seppia
Ti amo, ti voglio bene
- Ciao Gu ciao ospite, che dire, beh della
prima prima volta ormai un bel po' di
anni fa, posso solo dire che ricordo la
quantità de capocciate che ho dato sul muro
e il fatto di non riuscire a dirglielo, cioè al tipo in questione, ma mi ricordo
solamente il dolore della capoccia - E' un
classico però fa impressione che non
glielo dicesse - C'è chi apprezza
io conosco una ragazza, per esempio, che
si è fatta spaccare il naso contro un termosifone  - Ma apposta?
- Le piaceva proprio ... - Cioè lei non voleva che le
spaccasse davvero il naso? - Adrenalina a gogo - Lei diceva continua
Lei ha fatto continuare, ha finito tutto quanto. Ha finito e le hanno chiesto "Ma fai le
olimpiadi di boxe?"No è stata una serata
un pochino così, piccante
- Ciao Gu ciao ospite, scusate se parlo piano
ma si è fatta una certa, comunque volevo
raccontare un aneddoto un po' particolare.
Praticamente avendo io un problema alla
spalla destra, una lussazione cronica che
quindi ogni tanto, se faccio dei
movimenti un po' inconsulti
la spallina mi scappa via, mi esce di fuori
Allora una sera, mi ero appartato con questa
ragazza con cui mi frequentavo da un po', e giunti
finalmente al momento di consumare,
abbasso il sedile e una volta sopra di
lei mi fuoriuscì la spalla proprio nel
bel mezzo dell'atto. Inutile dire che
poi la serata preso una piega un po'
imbarazzante perché non mi si risollevò
ovviamente più la situazione sia per
l'imbarazzo sia per il fatto che comunque ci
misi un po' di tempo a far rientrare la
spalla dentro, e niente, questa è una delle tante disgrazie. Ciao un abbracio
- Non che ti esce la spalla, stai fermo. Immaginate la scena dove lui lo fa
gli esce la spalla e si rimette a rimetterla dentro
- Posso spezzare una lancia a suo favore
però? Uno che è bravo a mettere di nuovo
la spalla dentro, cioè deve essere un
cecchino
Di sicuro la torcia non la usa, quello è poco ma sicuro
- Che poi è un po' affascinante, quel sapore di medico      - Anche quel sapore
dell'imprevisto, che non puoi mai sapere che cosa
succederà - Magari a lei è piaciuto poi
- Non credo - Credo che il silenzio che ha seguito la tua osservazione ti abbia risposto - Ok scusate
Sto ancora pensando alla spalla che esce - Io a lui che è un cecchino
- Io a quella che ha lanciato la m***a dal finestrino...pensa te
- La mia prima volta ho diciamo ricattato il ragazzo che mi piaceva
a lui piaceva una mia amica e non io e io gli ho detto che se lui avesse fatto l'amore con me
io gli davo il numero di quella ragazza, e
così lui ha accettato e ho avuto la mia
prima volta e lui il numero della mia
amica che non se l'è filato di striscio
Per me questa tattica la usa ancora - Lei ha vinto - A me fa paura - Inquietava sia la
strategia ma anche un po' come l'ha esposta diciamo
- Io la prima volta che ho fatto sesso ho scorr****ato e non mi si è alzato l'uc****o
quindi è stata una prima volta veramente di m***a anche perché poi la ragazza mi ha lasciato il giorno dopo
- Nooo - Però ci sta - Nonho capito se era collegata - E' un palloncino dici?
- C'è stata tipo una dispersione di energia  - Questo video sarà molto difficile da montare
nel senso -  Perché
sono tutte cose troppo hardcore dici?
- Ho sbagliato io a dire che Tommaso Zorzi fosse difficile
- Ciao Gu volevo raccontarti della mia prima volta
io spezzo una lancia a favore di tutte
quelle ragazze che un giorno hanno
deciso di "sco***e!", come suggerisce la mia amica, ci teneva molto. Sono arrivata a 24 anni
senza ovviamente "sco***e!", avere nessun tipo di
rapporto, perché avevo deciso che dovevo
farlo con la persona che amavo, ma questa
persona da amare non arrivava e quindi a
un certo punto ho detto "Basta! E il primo
ragazzo che c'è stato ci sono stata anch'io
e poi non l'ho più visto. E' stato
bellissimo, perfetto e poi da lì in poi
solo felicità perché a un certo punto
basta no? - Sco***e! - Sco***e! - Glie l'ho buttato!
Vorrei sapere la prima volta dell'amica - L'amica è tipo il vino Ronco proprio
- E' vero romantico che aspetti il ragazzo che ami, non credo che lo faccia più nessuno
- Non l'ha fatto neanche lei alla fine
- Io conoscevo questa ragazza che non voleva far l'amore se non con la persona che avrebbe amato, per
cui girava la bistecca - Entrava da d****o
- Questa similitudine
della bistecca si usa per un altro problema però
pepe al sangue, giri la bistecca, quando la bistecca è al sangue la si gira - Mamma mia
ragazzi! - Questa è roba sua - No in realtà è sua - Qua, quel, non dico niente
- Andiamo avanti - Grazie per il tuo contributo
- Ciao Gu ciao ospite, la mia prima volta
è stata un completo disastro!
L'unica cosa che ricordo è l'aria che
faceva avanti e indietro e io guardavo la finestra
Non vedevo l'ora di tornare a casa, è
stata veramente
orrenda! Che schifo! .... Spero che la
battuta dell'area che fa avanti e
indietro voi l'abbiate capita. Stendiamo un velo pietoso sulle prime volte, che ne dici?
- No wait non ho capito
l'immagine di
no no no problemi problemi diciamo di
salamini tunnel si cela le tue capacità
di capire quello che dovresti dire cosa
significa salami nei tunnel
tu hai detto salani riteneva che sarà
mini tunnel
questa la nel tunnel cos'ha fatto che il
tunnel no allora
quello che ha detto nelson in esplicito
che ci racconta una prima volta felice o
quella della cacca non l'ho vista
turbato è uno di quegli anni che
racconta i gomiti aipo magari la nonna
- Volevo raccontare la mia prima volta, è stata bellissima! Il problema è che dovevo distrarmi dai fastidi
e per farlo ho dovuto recitare la trama intera del Gladiatore, compresi alcuni dialoghi. E' stato particolare
- "Al mio segnale scatenate
l'inferno!" di dante delle peggiori mali
generale che l'unico per l'imperatore
marco aurelio ennio film perfetto lei ha
sbagliato prima del sasso per
rimorchiare se veramente dei pezzi da
tenerla di queste righe animate di vinum
ai crampi e pd mentre lo stai facendo
Ciao Guglielmo ciao ospite
la prima volta che ho baciato il mio ragazzo è
stata particolare, infatti dopo sei mesi
di tira e molla, macelli in generale,
finalmente ci baciamo, si tratta più che
di un bacio di un limone durato cinque
minuti più o meno. Alla fine di questo
bacio epico lui mi guarda e mi dice "Ok
adesso vado a vomitare" e ovviamente io
sono rimasta malissimo. La verità è che
lui aveva mangiato una teglia di lasagne
e si è sentito proprio male, cioè in realtà lui
dopo ha vomitato
Comunque noi siamo ancora fidanzati - Ah bello dai - Bravissimi! L'amore vince
perché l'amore immagino tutto l'iter de
che sta per scoppiare si stacca e
composto da qualcuno dava a vedere il
guinness del primo dei primati dell'uicn
uomo geloso ma non lo so sarà tipo 27
ore omaggio tipo tre giorni che mettono
nei commenti chiedero nei conventi
fatecelo sapere prima di un bacio
solitamente di mangiona mentina non una
teglia di lasagne le lasagne più
l'energia per cinque minuti di rimonta
qual è allora la mia prima volta è stata
- Ciao Willwoosh, allora la mia prima volta è stata
non lo so, comica, perché tipo con mia madre mi sono inventata le peggio c*****e
per dirle "Voglio stare a casa da sola con me stessa"
e il giorno dopo mi sono ritrovata un
pacco di profilattici sul tavolo
co scritto sotto "lava i piatti", e vabbè
Poi è stato, io ero un tronco, ho camminato come
un pinguino per due giorni e ho creduto che
"Oddio che sofferenza sta roba! Ma
che è così? Nooo ma che scherziamo! Cioè niente
Vabbè bacioni ciao - Ma che dolce! Mi ha messo un grande allegria
- Loro a casa l'han sentita modificata, però noi che l'abbiamo sentita era pazzesca
- Ma secondo me modificata è ancora più bella, cioè è tipo Pingu - Lava i piatti con i
preservativi - Si questa è strana - Dici che se li mette alle mani? - Tipo guanti
- Buongiorno Guglielmo, buongiorno soprattutto a Enrico, tutto bene?
Allora la mia prima volta è stata abbastanza strana perché vedevo
ragazza che lavorava in un teatro. In
pratica per farla breve l'abbiamo fatto
proprio sul palco perché era vuoto
diciamo quel giorno. Niente sono v****o sul palco
e dopo circa un'ora, mezz'ora, venivano
gli attori e uno degli attori è scivolato
insomma ....ci siamo capiti - Ma scusa tu v***i sul palco e non pulisci?
Beh pulisci - Potrebbe essere sapone
al cetriolo, sono uguali alla fine - Hai presente?
- C'è una scena in un film famosa, forse in Oc - Beh Pasolini
- Comunque il problema della durata è comune a tanti italiani - Italiani... - Secondo me gli italiani sono un
po' un popolo sfigato da quel punto di vista- ...Andiamo avanti!
- Volevo soltanto dirti che è durato di più questo audio     - Te l'ho detto che è comune! E' comune
- Questo ragazzi è dissing - Di solito ti dicono "Vabbè dai non è un problema",
invece è un problema, le segna proprio l'anima
- Capito Nelson è anche da ingenui pensare che non lo sia
- Io do un consiglio, fate finta di nulla e continuate  - Io infatti questa cosa non l'ho mai capita
se dura poco l'antipasto, cioè, adoperati - Lo rifai, aspetti due secondi e  vai
- Ti prendi una siringa di cialis... è una cosa sana
- Ciao Guglielmo, beh che dire
la mia prima volta è stata imbarazzante, sono
stato quasi, com'è che si dice , liquidato
perché ero in camera con questa
ragazza
due anni più piccola di me. Sotto c'erano
dei miei amici. Mentre eravamo lì
nell'amplesso e tutto quanto, a una certa
parte la sigla di Gossip girl e lei si
blocca di colpo e mi dice "Scusami devo
andare, c'è la mia serie tv preferita
Si è rivestita e mi ha mollato lì sul letto - Che cattiva! - Eh ci rimani proprio male
- Capirei per Game oh Thrones - Scrubs, ma Gossip girl    - Per Oc
Raga si dice tanto degli uomini che sono delle merde con le ragazze ma le ragazze quando ci si
impegnano ... veramente distruggono vite - Ma vergognati! Oh vergognati
- Ohhhh ti devi vergognare! Nono fai bene, è giusto che qualcuno lo dica
- Il momento dove iniziò tutto mia madre mi chiamò e mi
disse al telefono se mi è successo
qualcosa. Quando sono tornata a casa era
un po' scioccata per questa cosa, però alla fine tutto apposto
- Vabbè tutto bene quel che finisce bene - Non ho capito - Era cosi tutto quanto? Non c'è un messaggio prima?
- Ciao Gu ciao a tutti, per la mia Vita Buttata per la prima volta (*suoni telefonici*)... - Ao e che è? Ma cos'è?
- ...ho dovuto smettere di farlo perché mi scappava da ca***e
- Aspè non ho sentito - Io ho
capito. Forse è meglio non sentirlo - Ok, andiamo avanti
- Se non altro non lo ha lanciato dal finestrino
- Noi lo stiamo nascondendo ma c'è a chi
piace - C'è a chi piace e molto
probabilmente sta tra noi 7. No che poi pensano che mi mangio la m***a. Nonono
Ragazzi siamo arrivati alla fine di  questo video, non so se ringraziarvi - Io farei un applauso
Grazie. Prima di salutarvi volevo dirvi
che questo martedì è uscito un video nel
loro canale, vi lascio il link qua sotto,
e se volete vedere io che rischio di
sbrattare ogni due secondi andate sul
loro canale, insomma lasciate un pollice
in su. Ah non la sciate un pollice in su sennò devo masticare i suoi... - Tarzanelli
- Detto ciò ringrazio di Space Valley - Grazie a te! - Che gran tempismo! E come sempre vi do un appuntamento
questa domenica con un'altra puntata di
Cucina Buttata - Ciao